My people can say it because of their
rejection and not having the world. My
name is Saro, the ball of churros
[Music]
When we go to
the room in Santa María, we
go, no one calls, nor does anyone wake up
or anything at 6:00 Pícate imprints, I paint myself
and tell them  the fart is beautiful for
the sargo says see you tomorrow goodbye
[Music]
we rest on a Monday and
Tuesday is coming your churrería is coming it is his
life
we ​​are in people being born in the South
father ourselves I have an uncle I
have all my family is  that's good I
now continue That's my mother
saw and you were left-handed for so many more
years
[Music]
one of the simplest recipes But you
can find in what is a
pastry this is simply water salt
and
flour boiling water
until bad and Back to  Point that it's
good, it's ready now and after without
oil
[Music] they
took out the wheat for us for me
like flour from the coarses,
Rogan arrives saying the little boys I
don't give you this I don't give you But I give you
and you can't pay tomorrow you pay me  He doesn't
pay me when he can, but he does
n't leave without a churro. There are
more stalls on the floor of the port.
But there are many people who come because of
my mother's character because they know that
she wrote a song there that she sang for her and
they see Brisas
but they were prayed in another place
[Music]
then they were my children and my grandchildren
even my grandchildren and there will never be a lack of money
or that even if I die as a
child I have to get up
a lot of work
[Music]